a six one seven eight three zero 4750
let's try our caller from the five three
zero area code caller from five three
zero who's this hello David my name is
God I'm calling from Sacramento great
what's going on Scott I wanted to get
your take on South Africa just passing
the land reform bill in their Congress
with the e FF and the ASD and what you
thought about that what the implications
might be going forward haven't read
about it yeah okay so I'm good
i I just I have some concerns about
private property rights and about what
what are the what are the implications
for some individual rights as well so if
you don't have a take that that's fine I
just it's been a concern of mine in the
last couple weeks yeah no I have not
read up on that yet it's been it's been
a pretty pretty busy couple of weeks but
I will hope to get to that sounds great
I'm a big fan since I saw you slaughter
Jesse Lee theatres their first exposure
to you and I was hilarious I
particularly related to your statement
about being a religious I thought that
was a really good day because I've been
struggling myself exactly that so thank
you very much
alright appreciate the call thank you
Jesse Lee Peterson convert I appreciate
it